primarily based on a joint work
um with dakshita Corona called
cryptography of a certified deletion
uh
so right
um I'll be talking about big commitments
all kind of informally Define them uh in
a second but
first I just want to say that they're
really Central primitive first of all In
classical cryptography for example we
know that they're implied by one-way
functions they apply one with functions
so they're a part of this whole uh
minicrypt set of assumptions that have
that have already been discussed a
couple times today they have a whole
bunch of applications I've just listed a
couple of more kind of direct
applications for example coin tossing
zero knowledge proofs arguments
um yeah but this talk is going to be
about commitments in a Quantum world and
so on the one hand uh you know what has
been discussed mostly in the morning is
that
uh Quantum and Quantum communication
allows us to build bit commitments from
assumptions that are potentially weaker
than one-way functions for example EFI
pairs uh suit around and Quantum States
on the other hand
um using Quantum communication we can
actually show the big commitments
without any extra assumptions give us a
whole uh new set of applications that
are not known classically okay so for
example oblivious transfer and secure
computation
a a bunch of Primitives starting with
commitments to certified Everlasting
hiding so this is going to be some
improvement in security that will only
follow using Quantum and various other
applications but for so this talk is
going to be mostly about the application
side of things I'm going to I'm going to
focus on this like these security
improvements we can get starting with
certified Everlasting hiding and along
the way I'll also kind of review this uh
construction of oblivious transfer from
commitments okay
and everything here is going to be built
just from like the black box use of
commitments which is important because
it means that everything on the left
here all these all these kind of other
assumptions sitting around in Quantum
States Etc
um will kind of directly imply then
everything on the right
okay
good so uh let me just uh say now what I
mean by like a standard bit commitment
scheme
um so it's a protocol between a
committer that wants to commit to a bit
b and a receiver
and the picture is just basically uh
that a committer sends the bit B inside
of a locked box to the receiver
and later they are able to open the
commitments and transmit the key to the
box so the receiver can look inside and
recover B and so you know very
informally I'll Define the standard bit
commitments to be one that are
statistically binding meaning even like
an unbounded uh committer cannot like
change their mind about the bit B that
they've transmitted in the first phase
of this protocol
and computationally hiding which is that
if the receiver is a is kind of quantum
polynomial time and they won't be able
to kind of just give them this box they
won't be able to guess the value of B
with any noticeable advantage
um and there's a couple there's a couple
kind of important
um
uh results that motivate this particular
definition of a standard bid commitment
one uh from the 90s Myers and low and
Chao showed that even
um with Quantum communication
you cannot obtain uh statistical binding
and statistical hiding at the same time
so we're going to necessarily have to
relax at least one of them to be
computational
and some other nice properties that kind
of follow
um in this Quantum world
um are that
um well one actually without internet
you should take any commitment scheming
without introducing any other
assumptions you can make it
non-attractive so just kind of you can
kind of have this picture in your mind
where the committer just sends uh kind
of one message to the receiver
and even in this non-attractive setting
we can kind of switch between
computational hiding statistical binding
or computational binding and statistical
hiding so these are kind of like the
same assumption okay so I'm just gonna
but usually in this talk when I say
standard bit commitment I'll refer to
the statistically binding
computationally hiding case
all right
good so
um this is the basic primitive I want to
start now
um with an application or like kind of a
strengthening of this notion of a
commitment that only becomes possible in
the quantum setting okay and this is
going to be a commitment with certified
Everlasting hiding okay so this is going
to look the same as a standard
commitment for now uh you can transmit
the box and the committer can uh later
open it
but they can also decide to do something
different so instead of opening the
commitment
they can ask the receiver okay actually
can you please delete the commitment
that I that I sent to you before
and the receiver should be able to
perform some sort of uh destructive
measurement on the quantum information
they received previously to produce a
certificate
which they can return to the committer
who will either accept or reject their
their certificate of deletion right and
so what we want out of this protocol now
is that
okay you know this will still be you
know we're starting with a standard
statistically binding computational
hiding commitment and we'll still assume
during the protocol that the receiver is
computationally bounded okay so
um if we assume that then they shouldn't
be able to recover the value of B online
during the protocol
but we want this extra kind of stronger
guarantee
um that after deletion
um you know condition on the committer
actually accepting the receiver's
certificate then the value of the bit B
which had previously been kind of in the
receiver's view just computationally
hidden it is now kind of completely
removed from their view so in particular
even if the receiver became kind of
completely unbounded time after uh
producing this certificate they should
not be able to learn anything about the
message that was committed yeah if you
want the certificate to be classical
um yeah Quantum the receiver can just
return the state right
um yeah I mean that's uh right that's
more of a like a revocable guarantee
yes but but yeah I both are interesting
but for this talk I'm going to be
considering um certificates that are
just classical
good
so right I guess
it depends how you want to make the
difference but like uh you can you can
usually I usually like call
um
Quantum certificates of deletion more
like a revocable cryptography where you
can like send the state first and then
revoke it later and this is like
deletion in the sense that the
certificate is classical so there really
must have been some destructive
measurement performed that kind of uh
got rid of the information it would
still get the same guarantee right it
would still be statistical
it would still be yeah exactly from the
review of the receiver it would still be
statistical yeah
yeah all right
okay so so right so this uh
I guess also just to just to
um Drive the point home that this is
like a Quantum notion right like
classically if this if this uh if this
box was just a classical thing the
receiver could copy it
um kind of delete or revoke one of the
copies and still hold on to the original
classical commitment so we would have no
hope of getting an everlasting
um security guarantee
um so this uh this primitive was
actually introduced
um by hiroko Mormon ishimati uh power
where they gave a construction of it in
the quantum random Oracle model
and so now what I want to talk about
is a construction of this primitive just
from the minimal Assumption of
um standard bit commitments okay
um and so this is my work with dakshita
and the commitment is pretty uh
straightforward actually and uh similar
to some prior work
um so the first thing that's going to
happen is the committer will sample uh
some Lambda bit string act some Lambda
bit string Theta and use these to Define
uh
poisoning Coatings bb84 States right
um so these These are each uh you know a
encoding of a bit X I either in the
standard or how to run basis depending
on the uh value of theta I
um so now we're going to use
um some of the bits of x to hide the bit
B that the committer wants to commit to
so let me Define the set s to be the the
indices here where Theta I is equal to
zero meaning
that
these indices are encoded in the
standard basis
the committer will kind of uh take their
bit B and mask it with all these uh X
I's in the standard basis and then send
over a a commitment to Theta and B Prime
yeah
so this I want to claim is a
statistically binding commitment to B
um
to open it we'll just have the committer
open uh the uh commitment scheme that
they used to send Theta and B Prime so
why does this allow the receiver to
recover B well all I have to do is just
kind of measure all these bb84 states in
the standard basis
okay that gives them some string X Prime
and once they know what Theta is they
know which bits
um of you know
which bits of X Prime will be relevant
for them to use to unmask the value of B
right so they can just you know once
they know Theta once Theta is opened
once B Prime is opened they can use B
Prime to recover the original bit B
um so this is how just standard commit
and open works for this protocol
so how would uh deletion work right
right
um
you know so instead the committer could
actually say you know instead of opening
this commitment I'd like you to delete
it and uh it's pretty straightforward
instead of measuring these states in the
standard basis to get the X size needed
to unmask B their saver will just
instead measure all of these states in
the hadamard basis so that should
intuitively erase all the information
about the X's that they needed uh to
recover B
okay and then they'll just return
whatever they whatever they uh get from
this measurement as the certificate back
uh to the committer
um and so the committer will check
you know we'll want to make sure that
the receiver actually performed this
hadamard basis measurements how do they
do that they basically check that the
string y that was returned matches the
X's that they encoded initially in the
hadamard basis positions because if the
receiver is being honest all of these
bits will match and even if the receiver
is being dishonest you know you can you
can show that if they if they pass this
check then they really should have
measured
um all or most of these states in the
hadamard basis roughly and therefore
kind of erased all the information about
X that was used to mask B therefore
remove information about B
all right yeah oh do you
will there be a Flipline to just have
the receiver like you know how the
receiver can just send the commitment
back to the committer
better
okay yeah maybe I that sounds like it
should work
entangled with the receiver right here
that problem doesn't exist
I mean it would be a different yeah I
mean I don't
think uh
I think it's
something
you're saying that after the commit
phase they would share your parents yeah
yeah
not necessarily did I tell you able.com
right yeah I mean yeah
classical
um
because it's equivalent to just sending
the whole state language which is what I
did in the very first in the uh like
2014 I just sent those three so it's
definitely easier but this means that
said that we need to hold on to a
Quantum state which is a restricted in a
practical lubrication
of the constructions of encryption Etc
can you obstruct out some properties you
need from the certification the good
employees yeah well it was
we have just a
favor
more of a general theorem about like
translating maybe a four states and
getting this let's get back that we can
use to build encryption or equipment so
but
yeah so
all right so yeah this is this is this
the uh the concept of uh commitments to
certified Everlasting hiding
um
okay so any other questions about this
I want to move on to some like
applications of this this notion now
so
um
the first application I want to discuss
is is called a certified Everlasting
zero knowledge proof okay so this is
also introduced in the same work hmny
and it's going to be a uh
first of all it's going to look like a
standard kind of statistically sound
proof say for NP with computational zero
knowledge
but at the end of the protocol we allow
the verifier to issue some certificate
of deletion okay and they guarantee
should be that if the if the approver
accepts this certificate then the output
of the simulator who's kind of
simulating a malicious verifier should
actually be statistically close to the
output of the malicious verifier right
so it's a similar type of guarantee
where online you have a computationally
bounded verifier
but if they delete at the end of the
protocol what we want to say what we
want to capture is that they have held
they now hold you know statistically no
information about the witness that was
used in the protocol they only learned
um
uh that the statement was true right
so
um so it's just it's like a proof that
satisfies this Everlasting notion of
zero knowledge if the verifier deletes
and so
I can give you like a little bit of
intuition I'm not going to go through
like a whole uh construction and proof
but some intuition about why this
commitment scheme should give us this
notion so let's consider a you know the
standard uh graph three coloring Sigma
protocol
um what we're going to do is just
replace the commitments in this protocol
with commitments with uh Everlasting
hiding okay so in this protocol approver
we'll just kind of send over commitments
to all the edges of this graph that they
know coloring for
the verifier we'll just choose a random
Edge and ask the prover to open that and
the proverb will do that okay
and so what we're going to add to this
protocol is the ability for the verifier
to basically delete all of the unopened
commitments right
so recall that in our ins in this in
this type of commitment scheme you can
either open it or you can delete it so
it doesn't really make sense to do both
but that still suffices for this
application because after this protocol
right the verifier kind of learned one
opening which is just one Edge and
they've statistically deleted
information about the colorings on like
all the other edges right so this is
something that can kind of be
statistically simulated
um
so and you can repeat this and get full
zero knowledge and so on so that's just
intuition about this
um
good uh now I can move on to you know so
I guess I chose zero knowledge because
it's a very uh typical application of
commitments at least classically
a um another application of commitments
that we know quantumly is to oblivious
transfer okay so
um
so here I'll explain what oblivious
transfer is we have a sender that has
two strings m0 and M1 and we have a
receiver that has a bit B and they're
going to interact and some interactive
protocol
um and at the end of the protocol we
want the receiver to learn M sub B so
one of the two Center strings but not
learn anything else about the other
string while we want uh kind of we don't
want the sender to learn what the
receiver's bit is and we want these to
hold even if these parties are malicious
or you know trying to deviate from the
protocol
and so this is oblivious transfer it's
very useful to has applications to more
General secure computation tasks
so let me review now a um a Quantum
construction of OT using just commitment
schemes and this goes back to an
original proposal due to crepo and
Killian
so again this protocol is going to start
like many other Quantum crypto protocols
with just transmitting bb84 States
okay
and
you know we're gonna basically at this
point
um use these states to set up like two
different channels like one in which the
receiver knows uh how to decode that
channel and one in which they don't and
so we're going to do that by just having
the receiver kind of ask the receiver to
just like measure these bb84 states
um they have no idea what bases the
sender chose so they'll choose their own
random bases and measure the states
okay so we'll get an X Prime right an X
Prime is going to match X at like
roughly half of its positions
um and in order to prove in order to
have the receiver actually proved to the
sender that they did these measurements
we're going to use a commitment scheme
so this is this is kind of the only
place where we use a commitment scheme
well the receiver commits to their basis
choices and their measurement results
we'll have the sender
um ask the receiver to open a random
subset of these commitments which the
receiver will do
and the sender will check that uh you
know for all of the indices
um where uh that were opened and where
the the choice of bases match the Theta
I is matched the receiver should have
gotten the same X right so the guarantee
is here the guarantee that we're going
for is that basically if this check
passes then the receiver kind of they
must have measured most if not all of
these states okay
um
so this is kind of like a measurement
check subprotocol and now we can
actually do the OT so the sender will
now give the receiver like the actual
States they used which will or the
actual bases they used which will allow
the receiver to Define kind of two
subsets like one subset where
um you know their Theta values match and
they actually know the X I's and one
subset where they don't okay and so
they'll set I set B the subset where
they know the Theta I's or the X size to
match the bit that they want to learn or
the string that they want to learn and
they'll set the other one appropriately
and these last two matches messages are
kind of the actual OT the receiver just
like sends over these the description of
these two sets and the sender will send
back encryptions of their two messages
using these different subsets of X okay
all right so that was a bit of a quick
uh review but
um
so the only crypto let's use here is
this commitment right and if we use a
standard let's say for now we're using
like a standard commitment it's like
statistically binding computationally
hiding we should get some guarantee like
this right where we have computational
security against the sender right
because that computational Security is
coming from the fact that they can't uh
break up with these commitment schemes
and learn you know which of these sets
corresponds to be
and we should get some statistical
security uh well we should get some
statistical security against the
receiver
um if these commitments are
statistically binding
um and there's been a lot of work on
this this protocol over the years
um you know these Works were mentioned
earlier today
um that basically showed that if we uh
if we showed how to build I guess
special types of commitment schemes in
particular like extractable and
equivocal equipment schemes I'm not
going to get into the details today but
they show how to construct special
commitment schemes that suffice to you
know to prove that this protocol is a
simulation secure OT protocol and then
implies secure computation
and actually you know the second work
actually shows that we can do this just
assuming um just from the Black Box use
of standard commitments
okay
um
good so now
yeah does it note at this protocol like
is not in relationship care which is
like regular commitments like your
intuition is very compelling and like do
we know that it's not a simulations
oh with with just like any so I
understand there's like a counter
example yeah like if you just argue like
it seems really like obviously
okay is it just the definitional
mismatch
yeah well
um
yeah I mean when you say simulation
security you need like an efficient
simulator right so that's where like it
probably won't be provable yeah
yeah
um
but okay it's all right
um but no I guess I guess what I want to
think about now is like well we if we
recall this is zero knowledge example
from before right we took those
commitments we replaced them with
certified Everlasting hiding commitments
and suddenly we boosted kind of uh
zero knowledge to this like stronger
notion of zero knowledge
so what happens if we just do the same
thing in this protocol let's just
replace these commitments with
commitments of a certified Everlasting
hiding so intuitively what should that
give us
well if the uh sender then kind of
deletes all of the unopened commitments
you know we should be guaranteed that at
that point we have switched from
computational security to statistical
security right so if they delete all the
unopened commitments then the guarantee
is that they know kind of statistically
nothing else about what was what was
encoded in those commitments and the
protocol should be statistically secure
against them
on the other hand I mean these
Commandments are statistically binding
um you know a prior there doesn't seem
any reason that we've affected uh
Security on the receiver's side so the
question is did we just construct
oblivious transfer with like Everlasting
Security in meaning like at the end of
the protocol if deletion accepts then um
kind of both parties can be unbounded
um
so it's not true we didn't do that one
reason is that it's actually impossible
to do
so
um actually uh so Dominic gunru uh about
10 years ago I guess showed that this is
impossible
um this being
um NPC secure computation NPC that's
secure against adversaries that are kind
of computationally bounded during the
protocol but unbounded after the
protocol and they showed this by
extending these bid commitment and
possibilities of
okay so we know that something must have
gone wrong
and what went wrong is that these
certificates of deletion
well actually basically allow the
receiver to essentially unmeasure the
sender's original Wisner encodings at
least for these indices that were not
previously opened right I'll I'll
explain what I mean by that in a bit but
at the high level these certificates
actually allow the receiver to kind of
back up unmeasure these uh States and
then measure them in the sender's bases
Theta and then kind of completely break
the protocol so learn both of the sender
strings
okay
so why is that why is that happening
we can look into the details a little
bit of this commitment with certified
Everlasting hiding protocol
the problem being that it doesn't Force
measurement after deletion so let's
consider a a one particular type of
specious committer specious just means
like actually an honest committer that
just purifies some of their actions in
the protocol right
so let's suppose that this is a
committer that wants to what they're
supposed to do is they're supposed to
take a state that the quantum state that
they start with they're supposed to
measure it and then they're supposed to
commit to the result of that measurement
okay so what they can do instead is
basically purify that measurement
um
which is you know here this last
register is the kind of like their
actual commitment uh to be and then
they're also going to purify instead of
sending bb84 States they're going to
send halves of epr pairs okay
so so actually what I'm doing here is
I'm saying uh let's have the committer
um you know actually measure actually
sample classical bases uh sample like a
classical bit B Prime and uh kind of
purify the bb84 states so the commitment
will actually look like this they'll
transmit like halves of these epr pairs
this register C along with like a
commitment to their to their Theta and B
Prime okay
yeah yeah
as you just argued it has to be a true
generic it has to be too generically but
this is this is like what goes wrong
with this particular construction
because I will fix it in some sense in a
little bit
um
so uh
so fun what happens now when the
receiver measures this commitment
register uh in the hadamard basis and
sends back over to Y there's sense y
back over to the committer
so if we look at the leftover state that
the committer has it looks like this at
this point right this this measurement
in the hadamard basis did not collapse
their X register I just put Y into the
face
and the committer you know they know
what B Prime is They Know It uh s is
they know what Y is the point is that
this R register now is like efficiently
computable for them and they can they
can uncompute it and they can kind of
recover their original state okay so if
they kind of
initially committed to this Alpha zero
zero plus Alpha One one and then they
received a deletion certificate from an
honest receiver they can kind of like
uncommit
in some sense and like return the
original state that they that they
started with which is exactly allows
them to break the OT protocol
um
okay
so
um
let's go back to this picture again and
so we basically saw that actually this
isn't this is an efficient attack that
the receiver can run
um so chemistry improved and there is
some room for improvement actually
um basically it said you know changed
insecure to computationally secure here
right so you can define a notion that we
refer to as Everlasting security
transfer
which is that
um even if the sender kind of deletes
the protocol doesn't become completely
insecure with respect to the receiver it
just becomes computationally secure so
essentially we've transferred
um we've switched a statistical and
computational security um between the
center and receiver by doing this
deletion procedure okay
and we know we can't do better than that
because of the impossibilities right but
on the other hand this is something that
is impossible classically
um so good it's a pretty simple at a
high level it's a pretty simple fix to
go from insecure to computationally
secure so let's recall this commitment
scheme one more time
and uh recall what happens after
deletion which is that we just transmit
this y
the observation basically is that this
attack that I just described requires
all of Y like the committer needed to
know exactly what Y is to uncompete that
register and return to their original
state right
but for correctness of like for like
checking deletion
it would have sufficed if the receiver
just transmitted the bits of Y uh in the
that we're in like S Bar S Bar is going
to be the indices that were originally
encoded in the hadamard basis okay of
course the receiver doesn't know which
of those which indices those were and
they can't
um but we're going to change this
commitment scheme we're going to change
the deletion certificate to like a a
deletion phase like an actual protocol
where instead of having the receiver
just transmit y they're going to first
commit to y
okay
and then they're going to get Theta
from the committer so now the committer
will open Theta which will basically
tell the receiver which bits of Y to
actually give the committer in the clear
so we'll uh so the receiver will now
only open to y s bar okay and these are
the only bits that the committer
actually has to check
so the point of this is now the
committer doesn't obtain a full
description of Y they can't launch the
attack from before they get a
computationally hidden description of Y
so this is why it becomes kind of like
you know this notion of binding which
I'm not going to actually get into we
actually Define it as like an
extractability notion but this notion of
binding from the committer's perspective
goes from statistically binding to like
computationally binding even after this
deletion phase okay
um
yes yes
yeah
okay
um
so so good this is what we Define to be
a commitment with Everlasting security
transfer and we can plug this in here
and we get the following notion OT with
Everlasting security transfer so they
can run the whole protocol and if they
decide at the end of the protocol they
can run a kind of a deletion procedure
which kind of switches their
um
security from computational to
statistical or vice versa
um
and I will just wrap up in a couple
minutes I want to give you just a little
bit of
more intuition like you know about
what this definition means or
what it looks like right so OT is just a
is a building block for building more
General secure computation protocols so
if I wanted to find a more General
protocol
um
it would look like this we we have two
parties each with some private input
they communicate and they want to learn
some function of those private inputs
okay after the protocol completes we
have the option of of you know party one
uh sending to party two a request to
delete if deletion occurs then we have
the guarantee that um you know now P2
knows nothing about X1
statistically except for what they
learned from the output of the protocol
okay and X2 should still be
computationally hidden from B1
but we also we can also do it the other
way we can have P2 requests that P1
deletes their data and get um symmetric
uh guarantees
so
the security is saying that after the
protocol basically either party can
request deletion even if even if the
protocol was to scare against them so
it's uh yeah I should say classically we
do know kind of one-sided statistical
one-sided computational protocols such
as zero knowledge or even 2pc but there
the party that we want statistical
security against is always fixed
beforehand and so this gives us some
more dynamic
notion I can mention one toy application
just also uh
uh maybe motivate the definition a
little bit
um you can imagine running a MPC for an
election right so you know these parties
are going to uh vote and elect two of
them to lead so say they elect like P2
and P3 be president and vice president
um
well what we could now use uh
Everlasting security security transfer
for is to have like basically the
citizens ask the elected parties to
delete their votes we could run a
deletion protocol and the guarantee now
is that the parties that were actually
elected and maybe are in control of law
enforcement or or whatever now they have
statistically no information about who
voted for them and who didn't right so
this is would only be possible with
Everlasting security transfer because we
wouldn't know beforehand too actually
was elected and who we want to get
statistical security against so
would this also be possible with the
protocol you showed us because not here
too many how to do this multi-party
thing from just shifting it in the OT
yeah yeah that's I I didn't cover that
but it's in the paper yeah so we show
like these uh you know uh composition
theorems and we can build NPC from from
OT with this notion yeah another
question of like an extension and it's
what I saw from this OT protocol is you
can basically flip it once but is there
something where you can just just keep
flipping back and forth yeah from time
to time for some reason they decide well
now I should have the uh yeah I think I
remember actually it was actually we
that came up and we're like oh
we didn't really like pursue it but we
uh
uh we thought that that is something
that might be possible but yeah but you
have an obvious Solutions yeah I think
there are some yeah I think there was
like I think it ran into some issue or
like maybe there maybe you could do it
like abounded number of times
um
you know you can do it for like other
Primitives like commitments for instance
with playing amendments can you like
switch the modes like statistical
updates
yeah I mean that's kind of like we'd um
actually yeah when we build OT starting
with commitments to satisfy that but you
have to be like okay what does it mean
you have to Define what it means to be
like statistic or binding and like
basically
uh
promo team right so maybe whatever
yeah well what we actually get is like a
notion of like
uh extractable commitments that where we
can go from statistics like
statistically extractable to
computationally extractable that's the
notion of binding
um meaning that like before before
deletion
um the extracted world and the real
world are statistically close but after
deletion they just become computational
so
all right uh I think that's all I wanted
to say just in summary uh we discussed a
few Primitives which are known now from
just the Black Box use of standard
commitments which themselves are implied
by you know these new Quantum
assumptions
um so oblivious transfer is an example
something where we get where you can use
quantum to get more functionality these
other Primitives are examples of using
Quantum to get kind of better security
okay and I you know
I don't know of any very specific open
problems but maybe there's other kind of
Novel applications of bit commitments in
a Quantum world uh that we don't know
yet so
yeah thanks for listening
[Applause]
foreign
issues but I
suppose if you start with
commitments with publicly verifiability
is just the case
yeah so with public verification you can
do it but you need one of my functions
so
um although if you want your public
verification if you let your public
verification key be Quantum then you can
use like one with State generators yeah
so that's of course
give me
um